so leute oh ich schäum mich doppelt moment
so jetzt wunderbar easy easy ich versuch mal easy as fuck zu treffen ob ich das hinkrieg
nein ist die katze irgendwo hier müsste easy as fuck sein da achte mal wie sieht es aus
in hanau weiß ich nicht wieso gibt es irgendwas was ich verpasst habe ich war heute beim aldi
wohl über dem grenzwert da gibt es einen grenzwert soll das für grenzwert sein und
wer hat den festgelegt mein grenzwert muss ja irgendwas muss irgendwas sein also was
für den grenzwert ich weiß es nicht grenzwert zu was vor allem grenzwert zu big brain 50
infektionen pro 100.000 einwohner gut aber was wollen sie jetzt machen das ist ja nicht
so dass die jetzt sagen können also korona virus jetzt bist du über dem grenzwert ich
weiß nicht was sie machen wollte ich mein ganz ehrlich wenn es nach mir geht ich habe
kein problem damit wenn die leute abstand halten müssen ich finde das vollkommen okay
mir kommen die leute eh schon jeden tag zu nahe die sollen sich alle mal ein bisschen
platz machen dann finde ich es gar nicht schlecht oder was ist mal gucken ob sie jetzt vielleicht
gibt es ja was zu hanau hier hanau und 5 achte schweiße was wie lange ist man eigentlich
kanake in deutschland oder über diese themen aber sagen so lange wie man sich so fühlt
die stadt hanau und mehrere kommunen haben auf die zuletzt in der gastronomie in schulen
und bei persönlichen kontakten herrschwieder verschärfte regeln ja verheißen ja wer hätte
das gedacht dass die leute am ende der ferien und wenn sie aus dem urlaub wieder kommen
was die zahlen hochgehen ja das war ja überhaupt nicht zu prädikten ja das hätte man nicht
denken das ging nicht vor allem reise rückkehr lesen die zahlen ja was wollen sie jetzt machen
treffen in öffentlichkeit mit maximal fünf personen ja who cares ich habe eh keine freunde
ich muss mich mit denen nicht treffen aber doch ich treffe mich tatsächlich mit dem
kamo mit zwei wochen in frankfurt seit das ist das erste was ich mache seit monaten
weniger besucher bei veranstaltungen ja dass das juckt mich überhaupt nicht spärstunde
in der astronomie zwischen 24 und 28 jetzt juckt mich auch überhaupt nicht maskenpflicht
im unterricht da frage ich mich wie sie das hinkriegen wollen ganz ehrlich ihr werdet
es nicht ihr werdet es nicht schaffen dass eine volle klasse 14 15 16 jähriger die ganze
zeit in der maske auf behält das kannst du vergessen warum schaffen wir es eigentlich
nicht mehr online unterricht zu machen weil kolumbien kriegt das hin aber wir sind zu
monat s bei uns ist das unding wenn die leute das geht nicht leute was online unterricht
wie was technik nee das geht nicht alles im grund hast du zwei firefox verknüpfen aus
dem desktop was nein das hier geht nach mozilla firefox de und das hier geht nach mozilla
firefox punkt exe nö es hat keinen sinn das hat es das hat er in store angelegt so
mit der zeit anscheinend so kein sport unterricht veranstaltungen einsport schwimmbad bei uns
ist eh schon nicht so voll diesmal das stärkte konnten ja das haben sie das letzte mal auch
gesagt und am maien haben sie oft auf der auf der wiese und am strand gelegen also von
wegen ach blödsinn also die meisten leute die sie nicht dran halten wollen halten sie
je nicht dran da wirst du auch nichts machen können was willst du machen wenn du leute
hast die sich hartnäckig nicht dran halten was willst du machen was willst du tun um
es mal zu sagen wie der echte gangster kannst ja schlecht den knast stecken bis korona vorbei
ist bußgeld ja aber ganz ehrlich im großen stil wird das nicht wird das nicht passieren
war ganz davon abgehängt abgesehen dass die polizei gar nicht überall gucken kann es
ist also da muss ich denke da ist jeder ein bisschen selbst gefragt sich da dran zu halten
aber es gibt ja welche die machen es absichtlich nicht die gehen zum beispiel auch in aldi
und also ich muss sagen letztens im aldi heute nicht so aber letztens im didel war ungefähr
ein drittel hatte die maske gar nicht auf oder aber hat die maske einfach so unterm
kinn oder übermunden nicht über der nase und so da ich glaube das ist eine kombination
aus leute die protest mäßig das machen da habe ich noch irgendwie gewisses verständnis
für ja kann ich noch irgendwie nachvollziehen wenn man damit quasi so protestieren möchte
so nach dem motto ich darf nur mit maske rein also ziehe ich die maske nicht richtig auf
das kann ich nur nachvollziehen was ich gar nicht nachvollziehen kann ist die leute zu
dumm sind also sprich die eine maske aufziehen und sie sich dann nur über den mund ziehen
anstatt anstatt über die nase das sind die oi 3 hat leute richtig oi 3 hat das sind die
kapiert nicht wofür das ding gedacht ist ja übrigens wir haben nicht allzu viel zeit
im stream ich war heute ich war heute einen ganzen tag damit beschäftigt nehmen wir ein
bisschen sachen aufräumen hier ich habe versucht arduino in esp edf zum laufen zu bekommen
und das geht auch aber irgendwie doch nicht richtig weiß ich ob das schon jemand gemacht
hat von euch es backt irgendwie rum weil ich wollte ein bisschen neuere versionen haben
weil ich habe gesehen da ist ein webserver mit htps eingebaut da brauche ich nicht mit
diese komische verbugte library verwenden naja ja patrick sehe ich auch so aber du hast
genug also guck nach berlin wo letztens um die 20.000 leute rum gerannt sind und bei
das ging dir noch ein paar andere sachen aber was ich ja witzig fand ist ich fand ich fand
es schon relativ beeindruckend dass man 20.000 leute zusammen bekommen hat ne für so ein
thema also sieht man das ist ein anliegen was die leute haben aber dass man sich danach
hinstellt und sagt es waren 1,3 millionen entgegen jeglicher beobachtung ist wieder low
brain klar sind die aus ganz deutschland angereist natürlich und angeblich ist jetzt
noch was angeblich ist jetzt noch demnächst eine aber bringen sie mein icon ist kaputt
warum ist mein terminal icon kaputt alles andere geht aber mein terminal icon ist kaputt
guck mal wenn ich mein terminal wenn ich wenn ich hier guck es euch mal an ich sage hier
computer das ist so dass ich höre immer das computer emoji hierfür und das ist kaputt
mein terminal icon ist kaputt das laptop laptop geht wahrscheinlich probier mal laptop aus
laptop geht guck mal laptop laptop emoji absolut kein problem computer emoji moment wait a minute
ok vielleicht habe ich einfach nur missed copy pasted guck hier ist nämlich auch falsch
vielleicht habe ich einfach nur missed missed copypaste warum habe ich denn hier meine workspace
ist da aha oi ich hab irgendwas dummes gemacht oder auch nicht aber gehen tut es gehen tut
es trotzdem nicht das wird also typische linux geschichte wo du dich fragst what the fuck
ist los alter warum ist es kaputt warum ist nur dieses eine alle anderen icon geht aber
dieses icon dieses eine icon das ist kaputt das ist das ist kaputt das das icon das geht
nicht ach guck mal jetzt ist er doppelt da ok wir machen mal nur zwei die leiste reloaded
nicht ok exit ok das hat schon mal funktioniert und jetzt was ist jetzt mit dem mit dem icon
hier reload miss reicht anscheinend nicht ok wann auch immer und aha exzellent wir haben
wieder eine icon sehr schön soll was das sein so jetzt können wir nämlich auch machen was
wir machen wollen und zwar ich werde mal kurz mal nur studio code ordner löschen also umbenennen
also quasi move code nee ach je wo ist denn das settings config config config config wie
es ein code ja wo ist denn der original studio config ordner über ach hier code da unten
so den move wir mal nach nach code.bug und wenn ich jetzt studio code starte hat es keine
plugins und nix ja weil ich habe nämlich heute wurde ich zugespammt irgendwie dachte reddit
und alles mögliche ich möchte und auf youtube vor allem auch heute morgen auf youtube schon
muss nicht immer e3 neu starten ja anscheinend schon ich habe refresh und das hat nicht gereicht
normalerweise reicht das aber keine ahnung warum das nicht gereicht hat zumindest hat
mich youtube heute morgen vollgespammt schon mit top 10 visual studio code plugins essential
must have die 8 besten die 15 besten die 70 besten die 120 besten die 20 die 5 besten
visual studio code plugins ich habe mir das zeug ein bisschen angeguckt ja und ich muss
sagen was da viele leute als essentials sehen ja aber mal gucken wir gehen jetzt mal so
möglichst unvoreingenommen ran und gucken was was ist was ist wirklich essential visual
studio code not just ja so dinger gibt es 30.000 sachen oder not just the top 10 was
schlägt er uns vor was schlägt er uns vor cs plugin ja also das mal außen vor also
ähm ups also irgendwelche language extensions meine ich nicht also sprich das hier ist für
mich jetzt auch essential wenn ich arduino zeug mache aber es ist nicht wirklich essential
im eigentlichen sinn übrigens muss man hier auf die settings und zwar activate extension
only when workspace is opened moment ich habe ein visual studio code ordner umbenannt warum
habe ich überhaupt noch extensions drauf was was ist das wo kommen die her warum habe
ich noch extension drauf ich habe mein ordner umbenannt nee habe ich nicht oder doch habe
ich warum sind noch extensions drauf muss man das jetzt verstehen muss man diese logik
jetzt echt verstehen ich meine ich hab's gelöscht ja ich hab's ich schmeiß es jetzt weg rm code
aufmachen und extensions sind noch da hä wo kommen die her kommen aus dem anderen ordner
ist es der falsche ordner gewesen wo kommen die her ach hier ist es anscheinend gar nicht
oder kann das sein ok we are settings stored linux doch nee also hier code gibt's nicht
ja doch guck da aber das habe ich gelöscht gerade was ist das für einen blödsinn warum
gibt's das zweimal was fack warum gibt's das zweimal ui so dann benennen wir das auch
um warum gibt's das doppelt so jetzt ist aber weg jetzt alles weg ja ok das sieht besser
aus willkommen nix offen alles klar so also was ist was ist was ist hier essential ich
mache mal kurz den chat auf dass ich nichts verpasse ja war was auch immer also nicht
zwei code install installation nee ich habe ich habe nur die offizielle es gibt auch noch
das da das habe ich aber nicht ich habe nur das aus community package das am einfachsten
kram zu installieren easy kurz chatgucke top 10 liste gucken wir uns gleich an vom von
wem von wem was supportic casino kapitalist sagt die eltern fahren bekannt waren auf der
corona demo jeder jeder jeder wie er macht persönlich wenn es auch fragwürdig dass also
nicht dahin zu fahren für seine meinung zu demonstrieren sondern die ansicht dahinter
finde ich bisschen merkwürdig wie man dazu kommt vor allem wenn ich mir gucken was da
was da für andere gestalten rumlaufen aber gut sonst machen ja wenn wenn sie der meinung
sind das ist das was man bewerben muss quasi dann ok so ich habe nichts übersehen sehr
gut der marketplace bei den open source builds ist aber nicht mehr der von microsoft only
kannst du einfach nicht alle extensions downloaden moment moment hä wie moment achso ja was
ok was zum geier ist das denn jetzt schon wieder warum gibt es michel studio code dreimal
hier drin die die können die leute aber auch verwirren oder ich meine wie es ko ich dachte
das ist eigentlich die die free variante dann gibt es die rüssel studio code bin und dann
gibt es die ko was was ist denn da jetzt der unterschied schon wieder dazwischen ok die
logik ich weiß ich versuche da gar nicht das zweite ist offisch ja aber das ist nicht in
den nicht in den quellen sondern ja was auch immer ja die bildnummer ist unterschiedlich
aber es muss unterschiedliche muss einen sinn geben warum es zwei warum es drei unterschiedliche
sachen im repo gibt es gibt zwei open source builds ok na mal gucken ob man alles installieren
kann welche sprachen benutzt du in vias code mal überlegen was benutze ich denn wie es
code cc plus plus platformer arduino esp 32 returns html css ja leider java script go
würde ich gerne verwenden allerdings ist go verbackt so dass ich nicht verwenden kann
allerdings ist go land eh die schönere variante was ist denn sonst noch was ist denn sonst
mal überlegen ich glaube das war es zum kurs also sie schabt mache ich definitiv nicht
mit studio ja go ist verbackt die schabt mache ich nicht mit mit studio code das ist eklig
im vergleich zu dem zu dem support wie man beispielsweise im richtigen studio hat also
sie schabt ist im richtigen studio oder ein writer tausendfach angenehmer heißen mache
ich recht selten ne das ist es nicht mache ich da noch irgendwas drin lassen wir überlegen
also kleinkram editiert wird immer mit wim also hier irgendwie so kleinscheiß auf der
kommandostage wird immer mit wim editiert da mache ich gar keinen vias code auf kannst
du genauer definieren warum go verbackt ist ja kann ich kann ich kann dir sogar das issue
zeigen ja da gibt es jetzt zwei weitere issues zack zack und eins ist noch auf genau das
hier so und die kriegen die createn sich hier ja einen schwanz an issues ok anscheinend
funktioniert das seit 19 tagen anscheinend funktioniert das seit 19 tagen oder vielleicht
auch nicht muss man ausprobieren das problem war mal und ich zeig sie ich zeig sie mal
das problem war wenn man interop mit c gemacht hat dann ist komplett sündags auto completion
sündags highlighting broken gewesen in visual studio code es hat gereicht wenn man import
c oben hinschreibt dann war das rechtliche feil im arsch was ziemlich doof ist wenn man
ein projekt hat was c interop braucht beziehungsweise eigentlich nur c interop braucht damit es aufgerufen
werden kann aus anderen sprachen also ich habe ja ich habe so eine web rtc webcam anwendung
gebastelt und die brauche also das hauptsächlich ist eine web anwendung in dort net aber die
web rtc geschichte geht halt über go weil go die beste library dafür hat und damit
man go aus dort net aufrufen kann muss man paar c funktionen exportieren und das ist
direkte rip wenn man import c rein macht vorher habe ich versucht mit einer mischung aus c
und go zu programmieren allerdings ging mir go mit der zeit echt auf den keks und deswegen
habe ich gedacht ich mache es wieder dort net davor habe ich interop gebraucht für ffmpeg
in go also egal wie man es dreht ich brauche auf jeden fall irgendwie was von c und da
war es komplett kaputt ja also gucken wir uns mal die essential extension an also ich
habe ein paar die ich tatsächlich ganz gut finde die zeige ich euch gleich dann auch
aber erstmal gucken was die essential code extensions was das ist ja genau also wie gesagt
das ist das was kaputt war so machen wir mal auf mal gucken und jetzt ist die frage installiere
ich installiere ich jetzt vielleicht das offizielle bild nicht dass ich irgendwelche super rekursive
irgendwelche high octane big brain extensions nicht verwenden kann rip grepp elektron ja
elektron kann immer weg wisst ihr übrigens eigentlich wem man elektron zu verdanken hat
wer ist da history mäßig wer kennt sich aus wem haben wir elektron zu verdanken leuten
die ich eigentlich sonst mag ja aber für elektron mag ich sie nicht wem haben elektron
zu verdanken chat ich sags euch github nicht ea ea wird mich nicht wundern github haben
wir das zu verdanken und zwar github hat einen editor rausgebracht der sich atom nennt oder
atom wie das die coolen leute sagen und das war der erste javascript editor und um diesen
javascript editor zu bauen haben sie quasi in gui framework nein gui framework ist dazu
wie gesagt haben sie eine möglichkeit gebraucht javascript auf dem desktop laufen zu lassen
mit gui und deswegen hieß elektron früher auch atom shell atom shell wir gehören zu
den coolen leuten wir sprechen das pro aus ja früher war elektron war atom shell und
daraus ist elektron entstanden als quasi browser in nem fenster für nen text editor
das allein ist schon so gestört aber das war so und das ist auch nicht das einzige projekt
es gibt dann auch noch elektron ns versus moment wie heißt das andere n hier nwgs gibt
es auch noch das ist auch so was wie elektron also quasi ein browser in nem fenster nein
da geh auf die seite gehen wir nicht übrigens wisst ihr was lustig finde dass seiten mit
ssl gefährlicher aussehen als seiten ohne ssl dabei sind seiten mit ssl mit abgelaufenen
zertifikat immer noch verschlüsselt im vergleich zu seiten ohne ssl ja das ist auch so ne sache
ja und den haben elektron zu verdanken ok installieren wir mal das offizielle visual
studio das uns microsoft auch schön tracken kann wann hattest du dein letztes date vor
letztes jahr weihnachten vor weihnachten vorletztes jahr ungefähr der chat weiß es
besser ich habs ja im chat sogar erzählt also nicht im chat erzählt dem chat erzählt
und dann hab ich verkackt weil ich mich nie wieder gemeldet hab oder was heißt nie wieder
gemeldet nicht gemeldet einfach einfach so wie ich halt immer mit mit leuten umgeh halt
die kennt mich ja also soziale zwischenmenschliche interaktion ist halt nicht so meins ja also
ist jetzt nicht so dass ich das nicht ganz nett fand und dass mir das nicht auch gefallen
hätte aber die überwindung mich dann weiter um soziale kontakte zu kümmern nachdem sie
mal angefangen haben die das ist das das ist für mich gewisse überwindung und das hab
ich nicht gemacht und wahrscheinlich hat sie sich gedacht so nachdem ob die ja der kell
soll sich mal soll sich mal rühren wir haben uns sogar was geschenkt zu weihnachten ja
und hab ich mich aber nicht dann ich hab einen set talks schlüssel talks schraubendreher
bekommen eigentlich eigentlich wäre das das signal gewesen dass das absolut big brain
grill am start ist wenn man talks schraubendreher kriegt ich stelle euch das mal vor ich hab
ihr schuhe geschenkt die man in der mikrowelle warm machen kann und mir einen satz talks
schraubendreher wäre talks schraubendreher geschenkt allerdings ist natürlich nicht
komplett allein auf die idee kommen muss man sagen ich hab das ich hab das ja erzählt
im vorfeld ja also das ist ja eigentlich eine kaufensaft ganz einfach dem thema dass
jeder hersteller sein eigenes supchen kocht bei irgendwelchen standards und bei irgendwelchen
schrauben und sonst was und am schlimmsten am schlimmsten sind eigentlich diese zwei
weiß ich ob ihr die kennt diese diese diese schraube diese wie soll man das beschreiben
diese schrauben öffnung die nur so zwei schlitzer haben diese ich weiß nicht was das heißt
so diese secure security smartphone schrauben keine ahnung wie die wie die dinger heißen
da wo man so einen spezialschlüssel für braucht und und da hatte keine ahnung ab was das ist
habe ich auf talks kennt so wenigstens talks kennt und ich wusste es auch nicht was das
talks schraube ist wenn wer weiß was das talks schraube ist vor allem dieses thema schon
wieder so talks schraube war sie sehr hübsch was ich finde schon allerdings also die mal
also ich gehe mal nicht davon aus dass die dass die meist leute denken würden dass dass
sie super hübsch war oder so aber ich fand diese echt gut aus ich habe ja nichts dagegen
wenn die middels auch ein bisschen kurviger sind ja muss ja nicht muss ja nicht alles
vom winde verweht vom zug mitgerissen werden ja bewo fed talks kennt doch jeder dann empfehle
ich dir mal wenn du mal wieder mit mit leuten sprichst die mit technik nichts zu tun haben
frag mal so nebenbei wann der wann die ihre letzte talks schraube rausgedreht haben du
bringst auch 120 kilo auf die wagen nömen eigentlich hab doch mal ich hab mich doch
so mal gewogen im stream
was war das mit den schuhen und der mikrowelle das verwirrt mich gerade es gibt schuhe die
kann man in der mikrowelle warm machen das hier warmis heißen jetzt früher hieß die
also die ist noch vor nicht allzu langer zeit slippies ach hier das sind das sind schuhe
das sind hausschuhe die kann man in der mikrowelle machen also das ob das optimale grillgeschenk
weil mediskalte füße haben da kann man in die kammer mikrowelle machen und da ist irgendwie
so ein material drin also das ist nicht fest unten das fühlt sich an als läufst du auf
auf sand wenn du damit also zum laufen sind nicht gedacht
genau also das ist wie wenn du auf sand läufst und die halten zwei stunden oder so die bleiben
relativ lang war maximal 100 grad oder wird man aber gedacht man möchte man fuß drauf
stellen so ja so viel zu dem thema aber ich habe mich da nicht mal gerührt und irgendwie
ja das ist bescheuert zwischenmenschliche interaktion ist nicht meins das ist ja mittlerweile
hinlänglich bekannt gegrillter fuß sehr hot hot gegrillter fuß so also frage ist von
matze 2090 kannst du jetzt als domain anbieter empfehlen habe ich noch nie verwendet aber
ganz ehrlich mein domain anbieter kannst du eigentlich kaum was falsch machen die
müssen noch nichts machen was muss so ein domain anbieter machen so ist es jetzt das
richtig echte studio code das legit originale von microsoft ja also als domain anbieter
kannst du doch eigentlich gar nichts falsch machen geh ruhig zu jetzt noch also wenn
du wenn du irgendwelche vm oder andere server bei jetzt noch hast und da im gleichen verwaltungs
panels domains haben willst mach doch das vorne kosten macht so einen großen unterschied
vielleicht ist es nicht der billigste weiß ich nicht aber so ultra teuer wird er nicht
sein dann hast du alles schön unter in einer oberfläche kannst du es darauf verwalten und
ganz ehrlich domain anbieter können eigentlich kaum was verkehrt machen was muss ich großartig
machen sie müssen in den dns record setzen dass sie dafür zuständig sind für die domain
also das aber das war es und im zweifelsfall kannst du die domain umziehen 123456 exakt
exzellent passwort beste passwort überhaupt so also jetzt kommen wir zu visual studio extensions
was was ist denn was ist denn essential so was ist denn essential it's not okay okay
so first and foremost settings sync ne will ich nicht ich will kein settings sync haben
weil ich gerne meine visual studios unterschiedlich konfiguriert habe ich habe zum beispiel das
code auf windows andere farben andere schriftgröße als das unter linux und auch plugins habe ich
andere so gucken wir mal weiter sort bei installs ja das können wir dann gucken aber das bringt
jetzt nicht so viel weil also programmiersprachen plugins ist jetzt nicht so spannend also die
nimmt man halt für wenn man die jeweilige sprache verwenden und logischerweise sind
programmiersprachen halt ganz oben als plugins ist ja logisch live server ist tatsächlich
essential wenn man ein bisschen frontend zeug macht jetzt wo ich es gerade sehe das habe
ich auch ins live server ist wirklich top also wer ein bisschen html sachen schon gemacht
hat wird es wahrscheinlich schon verwenden verwenden verwenden wenn nicht kann ich gleich
mal zeigen das ist wirklich tatsächlich eines der besten plugins warum checkst du regelmäßig
mein clipboard mach mal ausrufzeichen 1 darf ich das erklären kann man bei vias code so
profiler erstellen die dann individuelle nee leider nicht das kann das hat kein kein profiles
support du hast nur unterschiedliche workspaces aber das geht glaube ich nur um welche ordner
geöffnet sind so das ist wirklich toll weil damit kann man wenn man html zeug macht live
die seite aktualisieren lassen während man im editor tippt also sprich man hat links
seinen editor rechts seinen browser und man schreibt im editor was und speichert die seite
und der browser reflechten sich hier sieht man es ja und der browser reflechten sich
automatisch das ist das ist wirklich gut da ist hier auf der seite editiert was übrigens
super aufgelöstes gif editiert hier irgendwas und zack reflechten sich das das ist quasi
das ist sowas wie live reload ja nur dass man keine extra browser extension und sowas
braucht wobei es dafür sogar mittlerweile eine extra browser extension gibt es ist im
prinzip sowas wie live reload aber da ist wirklich gut also ein bisschen html macht
da ist das wirklich essential so also zeige ich mir was was empfiehlen sie noch settings
wie gesagt settings finde ich nicht so sinnvoll visual time to make your editor look beautiful
and helpful to viewers comes with great build in themes night all ich mag das visual studio
default theme das gefällt mir nicht zu blau aber ganz ehrlich das ist extrem geschmackssache
also ich habe zwei ich mag zwei zwei farbschemas ich einmal oder drei drei drei ich mag das
default das tatsächlich normalerweise bin ich nicht so der der der auf default sachen
steht aber ich mag das default farbschema von visual studio code das gefällt mir wirklich
gut und was ich auch mag ist base 16 tomorrow night und base 16 80s das habe ich hier in
meiner shell das ist das ist glaube ich base 16 tomorrow bin ich jetzt gar nicht so sicher
ehrlich gesagt profiles ne ich weiß gar nicht was das ich glaube das ist base 16 tomorrow
dark tomorrow night ist das so und das sind so die zwei farbschemen farbschemas die ich
mag ww ja tomorrow night ist das das ist das ist das farbschema am liebsten im terminal
und das default visual studio hab ich gefällt mir echt gut als standard farbschema von visual
studio code besser als sublime text sublime text hat hat viele fans aber das hat so viel
lila schrift was hältst du von material dark vs code habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt
ja und es was ich was ich auch mag ist wenn dass mein terminal und visual studio code
ein bisschen anderen look hat weil ich weiß es gibt viele leute die sagen ich möchte
überall exakt den einheitlichen look haben was für mich wichtig ist dass der hintergrund
recht ähnlich ist ja als die hintergrundfarbe weil wenn die hintergrundfarbe zu sehr abweicht
dann dann dann irritiert sich erst mal voll wenn du umschaltest ja aber ich mag dass
dass die farbschemas unterschiedlich sind weil ich im kopf besser um switchen kann
zwischen dem zeug was ich im terminal machen wollte und was ich im editor mache und deswegen
mag ich dass wenn das im editor alles ein bisschen steriler aussieht ich weiß nicht
ob das das richtige wort ist also ich habe es gerne wenn das im editor ein bisschen bisschen
reiner steriler aussieht und im terminal habe ich es gerne dreckiger klingt jetzt doof
aber irgendwie ist es so geschmackssache das hier passt auch von den farben her das ist
das ist verschwommener von den farben irgendwie als das hier ist ein bisschen steriler was
auch immer genug gelabert also dass das ist auf jeden fall nicht meins zu blau zu blau
und was ich gar nicht mag ist diese ist dieser trend zu denen ich habe vergessen wie diese
sorten schriftarten heißt es gibt ja so schriftarten die sowas hier zum beispiel fire a code oder
so die haben so spezielle wie heißt der kram noch mal liegen irgendwas mit ellie liggages
liga liggages wie spricht man das aus wir lassen uns das jetzt vorlesen ach so moment
ich habe hier gar kein sound wir müssen es mal ich muss jetzt vorlesen lassen wie das
heißt liggages liggages liggel okay und slow und slow liggages liggages okay alles klar
jetzt sind wir viel schlauer jetzt müssen wir mal bescheid ligatur moment das heißt
auf deutsch echt ligatur habe ich noch nie gehört noch nie verwendet da bin ich überhaupt
kein fan von leg daran wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten ich also mir ist klar dass
so ein fond zu verwenden gewisse umgewöhnung ist aber warum ich das nicht mag ist weil
es zu exotisch ist und zu exotisch in dem fall in der in der form weil das auf den meisten
anderen environments nicht so ist also wenn schon müsste ich quasi dann wirklich mein
terminal mal ein ganzes gedöns darauf umstellen dass ich das remote auf dem server auch so
habe wenn ich mich dran gewöhnt habe weil ansonsten hab ich so remote psh auf dem server
dort ist es beispielsweise dann ganz normal hier ausrufe zeichen gleich und hier ist es
dann sowas also dann muss das wenn schon gleich einheitlich sein max an die emojis mag ich
gegen die wort im emoji variable namen hätte ich gar nichts null und o unterscheiden mit
einem punkt ja das finde ich auch wichtig hier sowas das ist wichtig dass man das unterscheiden
kann ja deswegen mag ich das nicht so so also weitere essentials das sind das sind farbschemas
die gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an andromeda sieht ja aus wie ob am zirkus er damit könnte
ich damit könnte ich nicht arbeiten das ist ja pains jam wenn ich das schon sehe du kannst
übrigens auch die lila leiste und den vias code von der farbe und vom inhalt der enerja
ich weiß dass das geht bracket per colorizer ist must-have tatsächlich den verwende ich
normalerweise auch eines der plugins die ich tatsächlich mittlerweile default mäßig drinnen
hab weil ich hatte rainbow brackets im wim schon immer und den verwende ich auch immer
so also eiter eiter im sync brauche ich material design eiken warum brauche ich da unten warum
brauche ich da eikens das ist für für den file browser also hier hier gibt es dann hallo
ich möchte die datei anlegen darf ich nicht you have not opened a folder ok mk dir tem
dann öffne ich jetzt halt ein folder man will studio das um möchte so new folder html
ob es in nicht nur new folder mache ich dann new file html achso ja ich habe ja ich habe
meine settings weggeworfen das natürlich das ist natürlich doppelt bescheid gewesen ich meine
settings jetzt weggeschmissen haben font font wir brauchen hack hack brauche ich was hack
hack und jetzt schriftgröße 18 jawoll schriftgröße 22 ja ok vielleicht bisschen groß 20 weiß gar
nicht was ich hatte 20 ja 20 hatte ich ok was haben wir denn jetzt haben wir den ordentlichen
font ja die meinen wahrscheinlich eikens hierfür ha eikens für diese für diese dinger das kann
man machen ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass das super krass essential ist aber das ist
ganz nett das kann man verwenden das ist das lasse ich mir gefallen wenn das jemand als
essential sieht wenn er gerne eikens hat emet nein haben wir noch nicht haben wir noch nicht
aber emet ist auch super emet ist dieses zeug wo man diff mal drei und so schreiben kann dann
macht er drei diffs das läuft woanders unter sencoding und dann gibt es noch emet und es
gibt ein paar abwandlungen von peacock was ist das workspace color of your workspace
oh das ist gut das das das finde ich gut das das ist eine gute idee wenn man mehrere wish
studio codes offen hat dann ändert sich die farbe drumherum das ist cool das gefällt mir das muss
mal ausprobieren das ist das ist auch eine richtig gute idee moment da findet das hier wenn man
danach sucht mal gucken vielleicht kann man die farbe auch einstellen peacock da ist er so das
heißt jetzt wenn wir das hier aufmachen haben wir das so wenn wir es hier noch mal aufmachen
ist die farbe anders habe anders vielleicht muss er das noch konfigurieren
mal mal zumachen und wieder aufmachen ach unterschiedliche projekte nicht unterschiedliche
und also muss unterschiedliche ordner aufmachen ok ok ok verstehe verstehe create ok kann man machen
ok das heißt wenn wir hier was öffnen ist das die farbe und wenn wir keine ahnung jetzt gehen
wir mal hier documents platform iow display wenn wir hier was ändern ist eine andere farbe
ach man muss wirklich workspaces das ist aber doof ich erstelle nie workspaces
aber von der idee her finde ich es nice
aber von der idee her finde ich es nice muss ich echt mal sagen was ist die fault gewesen
ja von der idee her finde ich das cool aber ich verwende so gut wie nie workspaces aber
sollte das nicht schon wirklich jetzt unterschiedliche und das reicht ich mein die
ordner sind doch anders reicht das nicht ne anscheinend nicht aber trotzdem ganz ehrlich
die idee finde ich wirklich nicht übel weil man kann es ja auch von hand machen also man
kann das hier grün machen und man kann das war noch die die idee finde die idee finde ich
nicht schlecht du musst immer selber einstellen ja aber das ist schon ein bisschen blöd wenn sich
automatisch aber die idee finde ich gut weil wenn man ich habe meistens zwei studio codes
offen ich habe auf ich habe auf drei immer dass wenn du jetzt neu aufmacht solltest die farbe
behalten ok das probieren jetzt noch mal aus ok da muss man das wollte gerade da muss man
das einmalig einstellen ok das ist das in ordnung da kann man sich eine schöne farbe auch so das
gefällt mir was mir daran gut gefällt ist ich habe immer ich habe eigentlich immer zwei studio
codes sachen auf wenn ich zum beispiel über dieses aduino zeug macht und zwar habe ich auf drei immer
das ding wo ich gerade aktuell was mache und auf vier habe ich meistens irgendein altes
projekt aus auf aus dem ich copy pasten kann ich sage immer copy pasten ist keine schande
vor allem nicht wenn sein eigener code ist immer copy pastet nun was nun da ruhr haruno bestimmt
suchen wir noch was im controlling stonks leute suchen sie immer die idee finde ich gut das gefällt
mir das lasse ich mal installiert dass das das hat was das gefällt doch was haben wir sonst noch
für essentials sorry off topic benutzt du virtual box für die firm nein das ist vor
allem ein workstation virtual box funktioniert aber genauso also virtual box funktioniert genauso das
handling von von der oberfläche und alles insgesamt macht vor allem ein workstation einfach ein
bisschen runderen eindruck aber virtual box geht genauso ist kein kein ding so was haben wir
sonst noch vias code icons ist absichtlich jetzt gelb ok wie sieht das normalerweise aus braucht
man das ok normaler what the fuck drei so also machen wir mal ein ordner lull und dann machen
wir jetzt noch mal eine datei rein new file main punkt so ah moment c++ extension installieren
erst mal moment warum warum bei the way warum bin ich eigentlich warum warum ist c++ warum
muss es ausgerechnet c++ sein igitt kommen da jetzt müssen wir noch ein c-sharp fein machen
irgendwie dass man gescheite was gescheites hier haben was die endung von c-sharp tess
ala brain dead install mag streamt ja aber erst in einer halben stunde oder so so aber dafür die
letzten tage stundenlang ich glaube die letzten tage habe ich glaube ich zehn stunden zusammengestreamt
also sorry c lattenzaun ist es ja haben die den main makro hier was im box es ist windows forms
ok so excellent und wie kann man die wie kann man die change to a favorite color javascript
yellow node green view green das ist für frontend dudes aber noch darker das finde ich schick
so das heißt diese icons sind für ordner naja braucht man wirklich oder auf der anderen
seite wir probieren es mal aus ich mein optisch macht es vielleicht schon ein bisschen was
her anstatt so was hier probieren wir mal aus ich glaube nicht dass es für mich als ultra
essential durchgeht aber kann sie mal ausprobieren ach guck mal man kann sogar
auch ja auch jordes ist ganz nett
auch jordes gefällt mir das ordner eiken gefällt mir nicht chat was sagt ihr bern
bones ohne eikens oder mit eikens ich muss ehrlich sagen ich tendiere zu mit eikens
so was hat was war das andere was der noch empfohlen hat an eikens hier die material
eikens probieren wir die auch noch mal aus da muss man wahrscheinlich aber die extension
an installen mit eikens eikens gleich poc ok was macht das hier the most epic theme now
for visual studio kotter ein material design ist eh schon das neue bootstrap ich brauche
nicht meinen editor auch noch nach material design aussehen lassen mit eikens mag vielleicht
was anderes sein so also zeigt mal her das ist doch mehr oder weniger exakt das gleiche
nur in blau das ist doch überhaupt kein unterschied das ist einfach nur blau anstatt grün und
gedings sogar das ordnersymbol sieht gleich hässlich aus aninstall nehmen wir das andere
da gibt es noch andere flavors ok probieren wir es noch mal aus eikens eikens ok ich installiere
es noch mal ach hier set file eiken theme kann man die parallel installieren aha man
kann die parallel installieren
man kann die parallel installieren das ist natürlich nicht schlecht ok das finde ich
ganz gut aber ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen mir gefallen die anderen gefallen hier besser
wobei so wirklich überzeugt von den eikens bin ich nicht also also ja eikens sind gut
aber wo vias code create eikens a big der wills aber wissen aber beides gefällt mir
nicht so gut weder das ist noch das aber ich lasse jetzt mal das ein das andere hau
ich wieder weg wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp alter da wuppelt sich aber ein ab das war mal wieder
weg reload ähja all die klappe was nomo dark eikens ok ok probieren mal aus nomo dark eikens
wenn der chat das vorschlägt testen wir das mal ok wo hier nomo ok vielleicht sieht es
noch auf den ersten blick schlimm aus weil das bild schlechte seitenverhältnis hat
vielleicht ist besser wenn man es installiert hat ja ist besser ja gefällt mir besser wobei
das html gefällt mir gar nicht komm wir halten uns jetzt nicht ewig wir halten uns jetzt
nicht ewig an irgendwelchen eikens auf ist geschmackssache mit den eikens moment install
also was ich hier ganz gut finde ist dass der hier das html 5 symbol für html dateien
hat also error lens ja ich muss ich gucke jetzt erstmal der reihe nach was was der hier
noch so vorschlägt dann aber wir haben gar nicht mehr so viel zeit vielleicht morgen
einfach weiter so also das hatten wir schon nochmal peacock hatte das nicht grad schon
vorgeschlagen bracket colorizer 2 ja das ding ist wirklich poggers der bracket colorizer
den verwende ich auch gucken ob sie schöne bildchen haben genau das ist wirklich super
den kann ich auch wirklich empfehlen wo der unterschied zwischen 1 und 2 ist bin ich
habe ehrlich gesagt überfragt ok bastion 2 ist schneller bastion 2 ist schneller guck
der macht jetzt hier sowas der färbt die ups der färbt der färbt die klammern ein
also gehen wir mal irgendwie hier rein und sagen jetzt achso das ist das ist tipp irgendwie
rein keine ahnung was gibt es hier list hier gibt nix ja ich mache jetzt einfach mal klammern
und da sieht man schon der färbt die klammern unterschiedlich das ist sehr praktisch das
heißt man sieht immer wo man ist und er zeigt auch den scope anguckt guckt euch mal hier
an der macht der mal einen der mal einen fahrt von der ein klammer zu anderen das heißt
man sieht genau was dabei ist im klammern das ist wirklich sehr praktisch das habe ich
auch überall installiert da kann man nichts sagen gibt es hier nicht irgendwie ein template
für eine komplette für eine komplette einstiegsklasse oder so so main oder sowas main einfach dass
man was ausprobieren kann name space using system collections list generic achso class
ja genau und hier sieht man jetzt schön mit den klammern guckt da da da klammer und selbst
wenn man jetzt hier list initializer macht dann stimmt das das ist wirklich sehr praktisch
also da kann ich das kann ich wirklich empfehlen so was kriegen wir noch vorgeschlagen 2 ist
bestimmt machine learning das das wäre mal was heute gibt es alles mit machine learning
machine learning klammern highlighter was könnte man da machine learning welche farben
am besten lesbar sind oder sowas oder oder unbekannte klammern typen lernen oder was
auch immer wie kann man in vias code den gesamten scope zwischen zwei klammern selektieren
keine ahnung ich kenne mich mit ich kann ja ich kann ja wim shortcuts für so dinger sagen
aber visual studio code shortcuts habe ich keinen plan visual studio code wäre ich zum
aus clicker doppel click auf eine klammer ob das geht glaubt das geht nicht aber vielleicht
kann man alt oder so nee keine ahnung in wim ist es relativ einfach in wim kannst du
beispielsweise sagen ciw dann löschte alles zwischen zwischen nicht nicht ci klammer
dann löschte alles zwischen den klammern oder faul klammer dann selektiert er alles
zwischen den klammern es gibt einen addon für wim tasten kombination weiß ich aber
ich komme mit den ganzen wim plugins nicht klar ich bin im kopf nicht im wim wenn ich
in solchen programmen bin ich bin nur im wim im wim also nur wenn ich auf dem terminal
im wim bin hab denke ich in wim shortcuts wenn ich in wenn ich hier in visual studio code
bin hab ich keine wim ich hab mal einen neowim plugin ausprobiert weil da angeblich auch
noch wim plugins in visual studio code aber das ist total am abkacken gewesen copy paste
ist hart in wim kommt drauf an was man eingestellt hat also wenn man wenn man ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich sie eingeschaltet du kannst einfach markieren und dann hast du es hier
in der zwischen hast du nicht ok ich habe nicht richtig normalerweise machst du also
im moment habe ich nur habe ich den num block überhaupt an aber ich habe den num block
gar nicht an deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert kannst markieren antrückst du moment wie
heißt anführungszeichen oben plus y und dann hast du das copy ne hast du what the fuck
warum nicht habe ich keinen clipboard support hier drinnen also normalerweise geht das sternchen
geht auch vielleicht ok also normalerweise normalerweise drückst du so das oder das
irgendwie habe ich keinen clipboard support frag mich nicht ich habe mich hier nicht
einrichtet ihr kümmert bis jetzt aber ich gebe dir recht copy paste ist eine sache für
sich aber was ganz praktisch ist es gibt eine coole erweiterung ich habe hier keine erweiterung
ins steht die zeigt dir die register an sobald du anführungszeichen drückst das ist eine
der wim erweiterungen die sind wirklich sinnvoll zu verwenden so das haben wir highlight matching
tag das ist glaube ich auch recht praktisch das ist für html leute bestimmt ganz praktisch
dann siehst du den öffnen open close tag aber es hat schlechte bewertungen aber das
ist schlecht moment das hat ads das ist eine erweiterung die werbung spammt die installieren
und schon mal nicht du suchst einen editor der in c++ klassenmemberfelder anders färbt
als lokale variablen scheinbar kann das wirklich nur clips also ich habe da von c++ keine ahnung
in der richtung in wishlist studio counting und ich verwende das nur ein bisschen arduino
zeug dabei aber vom richtigen studio bei dort nett weiß ich dass man da wirklich jeden
scheiß einstellen kann das heißt ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man auch aber ich weiß
halt nicht wie irgendwelche richtigen einstellen kann aber zumindest was ist was ist auf jeden
ja bei c++ kann sein aber bei bei sich ab kannst auf jeden fall ob sie leihen kann
könnte man vielleicht mal ausprobieren weil bevor ich eclipse verwende für c++ würde
ich lieber sie leihen verwenden kann man wie es code change highlighting gibt es da gibt
es ja wieder hier eine wissenschaft für sich wie man da was nee hier kannst du es anscheinend
nicht einstellen das müsste was die member highlight oder sowas geben du scheiß aber
30 milliarden sachen kannst du einstellen das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf what the fuck
was wir was kriegen wir sonst empfohlen color highlight highlights color values in das ist
tatsächlich praktisch wenn man html zeug macht der zeigt dir an also sowas sowas ist
top wenn man wenn man öfters html macht der zeigt dir die farbe an neben dem fab tag wobei
ich glaube dass das studio code in css sogar sogar selbst mittlerweile kann probieren wir
mal aus style font color nee text css einfach nur text color nee aber was war es dann font
background nee bg ach du scheiße color nur color ja genau ja guck die können sowas kann
er auch sowas hier dann highlighten ja also das kann visual studio code mittlerweile eingebaut
allerdings das hier zeigt auch im html so aus code an so in der das ist tatsächlich cool das
habe ich ausprobiert aber das war mir zu anstrengend das das finde ich nicht schlecht
von der idee das plugin gerade wenn man kaut hat er ein bisschen tiefer eingerückt ist kann es ja
mal installieren dass man sieht das war mir aber zu viel des guten guckt hier da kriegt man
angezeigt wo man gerade in der eindrückungstiefe ist ja das gibt bestimmt viele den das gefällt
ich fand es zu viel des guten ich fand es zu viel des guten ja weil man angenommen man hat
jetzt keine ahnung hier was wir war list filter nee feind aber wir müssen link hat das
nicht in klunen so und wenn du dann hier noch irgendwelche sachen hast irgendwie sowas dann
wird es langsam etwas unübersichtlich wenn man so abgedrehte sachen wie er lang macht
hört es gar nicht mal das blickste gar nicht mehr durch ja und wenn dann hier noch irgendwelche
anderen dinger machst dann dann wird dann wird es zu viel dann wird es dann wird es echt echt
zu viel ja ne ne ne das das fand ich ist eine gute idee aber das ist mir optisch optisch ist
mir das zu zu überladen das war mir zu viel so image preview macht was it looks like this
achso nee das brauche ich nicht das das das geführt mir glaube ich auf dem kick skin
output debug panels locks ibm was da los aber von der idee ist eigentlich ganz gut lock highlighter
last commit von vor drei jahren ok nein ich nehme nur sachen die active developed werden
better comments helpt auch ja das ganz praktisch was ich was ich mittlerweile ganz gern verwende
ist das hier das ist so was ähnliches vielleicht ist das hier sogar besser das hier finde ich
to do highlight hieß das das finde ich ganz praktisch wie gesagt ich ich mag ja so sachen
die einfach nur eine sache machen und sonst nix und das hier ist ganz praktisch wenn man
zum beispiel hier reingeht und sagt was was es macht wenn man hier reingeht und sagt dann
zum beispiel to do dann heileite dass das to do tree habe ich auch ja das finde ich
praktisch to do tree mag ich auch da kann man nämlich die ganzen to dos von einem projekt
sich anzeigen lassen auf einmal und man kann auch einstellen dass es nicht die files von
anderen anzeigt so normalerweise sollte jetzt eigentlich ein to do anzeigen macht er aber
nicht weil warum warum nicht weil ich nicht gespeichert habe hier da kriegt man nämlich
alle dateien angezeigt wo noch to dos drin das sind da finde ich ganz nützlich ja gucke
ich nicht so oft rein aber ich bin ja mittlerweile ein ziemlich ausführlicher to do schreiber
also weil ich die sachen sachen vergessen zum beispiel hat letztens im stream jemand
gesagt an der stelle wo ich da von hand eine progress bar zusammen gewürstet habe nehmen
doch nehmen doch die arduino map funktion so dann würde ich hinschreiben hier arduino
map so wenn man es richtig schreiben kann würde ich dann drüber schreiben und gut ist
kann das auch was anderes kann habe ich noch nie auswählen fix me kann er nämlich auch
fix me was kann er noch was kann er to do the highlighter dann noch das habe ich ich
mache eigentlich nur to do ich weiß gar nicht was der was der noch kann note note nee kann
der moment wo ist er ah du highlight also to do fix me ane kann nur kann nur to do fix
me reicht ja auch keyword patterns ane kann auch mehr wahrscheinlich was man kann man
kann selbst keywords definieren und dann farben dazu vergeben ok ist aber echt praktisch auch
die to do tree variante man muss allerdings gucken also man kann sicherlich richtung studio
code auch unnütz langsam machen das hier finde ich aber eigentlich auch ganz cool man
kann mit 30 das bisschen wie wim ja wim ist auch wenn man voll aufbaut mit plugins teilweise
mega lab das kann man schaffen mit visual studio code bestimmt auch ok das ist so was
ähnliches hier improve your code commenting bei also sprich der kann alerts queries to
do's aber ganz ehrlich das andere kann das auch da muss ich selbst definieren wir vergleichen
das mal wir vergleichen das jetzt mal wir haben hier better comments und ich deinstallier
das was ich da also wie gesagt das da das verwende ich ja ganz gerne jetzt probieren
mal das da aus ob das das irgendwie schöner macht so better comments fix me ok das auch
was hat er sonst noch note nee alert ach man kann ein ausrufezeichen davor machen ok
das finde ich das finde ich nett
guckt ihr mal power mode an das finde ich ganz nett hier muss ich ehrlich sagen das
hat was was war das andere fragezeichen das ist ganz nett macht er denn standardmäßig
to do fix me ausrufezeichen fragezeichen slash slash to do was warum muss das unterschiedliche
sprachen supporten also das erkennt wenn es comments sind ja ok was power mode power mode
ist das das wo es blinkt an der stelle wo es wo es wo es wo es farbe sprüht dort wo
man tippt oder ist es was anderes ja das kenne ich genau ja das kenne ich ok das ist
eher just for fun weil das macht den editor bestimmt lahm wie sau man kann es man muss
wahrscheinlich aktivieren power wie aktiviert man das denn to enable add true to your settings
warum kann man es nicht einfach einschalten für ich will es nicht in den settings einschalten
ok also power mode enable enable power mode jetzt geht's ab bam ok das sieht aber in
der das sah aber in der vorschau schöner aus was gibt es denn da noch andere sachen
presets power mode presets das müssen wir jetzt noch mal ausbringen power mode was kam
aus die extensions power mode wo kann man hier umstellen wo kann man hier umstellen
was er macht ah hier presets fireworks so scheiße hat er noch blames das ist für die
richtigen hacker man unter uns magic das load aber schon ganz schön klippi oh nein na das
muss sich euer ernst ich muss klippi verstecken klippi weg klippi simple was ein blödsinn
es ist komplett sinnlos aber eben ganz witzig aber nix was ich nix was ich essential nennen
würde und schon mal gar nichts was ich jeden tag an haben würde an install weg ok was
haben wir sonst noch schönes highlight line moment macht es das nicht standardmäßig
schon ich mach aber ich sehe ich also im wimm habe ich immer eingestellt dass ich die die
die zeile eigentlich gehighlightet kriege aber irgendwie doch ist auch hier ist auch
im visual studio schon in visual studio schon highlighted wollte gerade sagen weil ich hier
verliere ich die zeile nie oder macht es was anderes die aber die ist auch schon highlighted
woops die die die ist auch schon highlighted brauche man nicht brauche man nicht unsinnig
ja über kann sie ihn immer einstellen dass der hintergrund sich ändert ich glaube das
liegt daran weil ich weil das color scheme kaputt ist in dented block highlighting
ach der zeigt von wo bis wo was geht ne das ist zu viel das ist da passiert mir zu viel
auf dem bildschirm language ok language filesupport müssen wir nicht schauen language filesupport
ist klar wenn man wenn man die jeweilige sache benutzt dann braucht man das halt auch
fertig xml tools gehst du mal fort lit was ist lit html lit as fuck add sundags highlighting
in language of html insa warum ok also chat chat ich verstehe warum man javascript in
html macht aber warum macht man html in javascript das einzige was mir einfällt sind react render
dinger aber dafür gibt es ein eigenes jsx plugin ok ja doch für irgendwelche template
sachen leuchtet ja doch leuchte doch ein ja wenn man es braucht ist nett ansonsten ist
definitiv nicht essential doch hier das docker plugin ist wirklich ganz nett ich hab das
auf der auf der azure schulung verwendet für da war stocker unter windows teile eklige
aber das war wirklich ganz nützlich dass ich das auch automatisch connectet und da
sachen ist ganz nützlich aber brauche tut man es nicht warum gibt es ein visual studio
cupanates was hat cupanates mit meinem editor zu tun ja das stimmt das stimmt wirklich die
arduino ide ist ja eigentlich ganz cool weil man viele sachen einstellen kann partitionierung
die geschwindigkeit von der seriellen schnitt stellen ganz viele sachen sind im menü drin
aber der editor von der arduino ide ist wirklich absoluter crap totaler müll die haben mal
vor zwei jahren ne beta version rausgebracht von der arduino ide die code completion hatte
das heißt bis heute nicht rausgekommen war echt zu verbuggt und seit ich visual studio
cupanates mit platformer auf verwende habe ich nie wieder die arduino ide verwendet ich
habe das relativ früh entdeckt das heißt ich habe so gut wie nie die arduino ide aber
arduino ide ist wirklich grausamst da braucht man übrigens auch kein extra extra arduino
addon ist komplett overrated platformer ist eines der besten plugins die man sich vorstellen
kann dafür die arbeit einer arduino pro ide ok wie gesagt platformer ist das beste was
gibt dafür ascii docs sagt mir irgendwas das sieht ein bisschen aus wie markdown ehrlich
gesagt was ist der unterschied sieht ein bisschen aus wie das doku wiki format ja sieht ein
bisschen aus wie doku wiki warum nimmt man lieber ascii docs als markdown markdown hat
auch den riesen vorteil dass es weit verbreitet ist was mal was in altera quatus gemacht wird
in schulen verwendet um fpga und socks zu nein habe ich noch nie ascii doc kann mir ich
muss ja sagen dass ich war mal eine zeit lang voll auf dem markdown trip so nach dem motto
alles in markdown und immer mit preview mittlerweile bin ich immer noch auf dem markdown trip aber
ich mache mittlerweile alles in markdown sofern es geht allerdings ohne vorschau ich verwende
markdown rein für strukturieren von rein für strukturieren im moment wie war wie war fett
also nicht fett schreiben doch ne moment zusammen ist blöd also ich verwende markdown nur noch
rein fürs strukturieren über sind sind als ein ding von text und wenn man mal was rendern
muss halbwegs hübsch dann kann man es damit machen also sprich zum beispiel unser komplettes
changelog auf der arbeit ist in markdown ich guck mir nie die seite an aber einmal im monat
mache ich aus dem changelog eine html seite dass ich alle freuen können was für ein tolles
changelog haben und was hier auch ganz praktisch du kannst auch sündags highlighting für sprachen
und so machen 1 2 3 4 wie war die ruby sündags dafür nochmal so ganz lang kein ruby mehr
gemacht das finde ich auch an markdown ganz praktisch dass schon zumindest hier in visual
studio corten im standard mäßigen den die sündags highlighting für alle möglichen
sprachen ist man könnte jetzt natürlich ganz abgedreht sein hier drin auch anfangen irgendwie
c++ zu programmieren also den kram da rein kopieren von hier gucken was der mit den highlights
macht bin ich mal gespannt gucken ob das das plugin hinkriegt ja da versagt doch immerhin
to do und fix me kann es highlighting und das wäre jetzt natürlich richtig pro hätte das
hier drinnen noch irgendwelche c++ highlights jetzt wäre es jetzt ja also das ist eigentlich
der einzige grund warum ich so viel markdown verwende weil das eben schön strukturieren
kannst weiß die coolen leute verwenden ja im ex org mode und sowas weil das schön strukturieren
kannst und mal rendern wenn es drauf ankommt so was haben wir sonst noch für sachen die uns
hier empfohlen werden brauche man alles nicht was ist mdx x in markdown falls jetzt jetzt
wollen sie aber wissen code navigation code ist jumper der ist jumper was was was schampter
moment das ist sowas wie sneak in wimmer ja das ist das ist sowas wie sneak oder oder
wie heißt das andere in wimmer das ist sowas hier der zeigt also sprich du gibst du drückst
es und ein buchstaben und da zeigt dir quasi alle vorkommen an und du drückst dann das
nächste und kannst dann springen zu dem was geheiligt ist also im prinzip sowas hier du
drückst du drückst den knopf oder highlighted die wörter du kannst direkt dahinspringen
ohne dass das anklicken muss glaube ich glaube zumindest dass das sowas ist es gab aber in
wim eine andere extension die haben euch den namen vergessen haben die das die das schöner
gemacht hat das ist das das war es ist ganz praktisch auch verwende es eigentlich auch
im total selten easy motion genau easy motion meine ich easy motion war das easy motion
also quasi hier easy motion das war praktisch ja ist das ein video ja genau da kriegst du
es angezeigt guck du gibst was ein und du kannst dann direkt dort hinspringen mit also
gibts jetzt hier kannst wenn du fm drückst m drückst springt er dahin allerdings braucht
man das meistens gar nicht so sehr weil du kannst mit f und dem zeichen in wim in der
gleichen zeile dahinspringen wo du willst ok was haben wir sonst noch bookmarks sowas
wie such fort enter ja nee such fort enter ist ja er highlighted dir alles du kannst
damit n vorn zurückspringen dort highlighted dir das und du gibst dann eine sache ein und
er springt genau an die stelle wo du haben willst so bookmarks ich glaube sowas brauche
ich nicht ich glaube das das ist das ist so ein typisches ding wenn ich das installiere
ich denke mir auch cooles plugin kann man mal verwenden ich werde es nie verwenden das
weiß ich jetzt schon aber ich gebe dir mal eine chance es klingt nach einer guten idee
es klingt nach einer guten idee vor allem wenn man ein bisschen längeren code hat
vor allem ein bisschen ok wir machen mal wir machen mal kurz das projekt von gestern
auf documents platform i o display code codra so und jetzt mal ein bisschen was längeres
auf hier display so und wie kann man jetzt bookmarks machen ok also sagen wir mal ich
ich such immer was suche ich dann immer die dort wo ich den task starte bookmarks ok was
kann man machen bookmarks selection bookmarks selected lines was bookmark achso ich muss
die zeile auch selecten to do sind schon besser als bookmarks aber wenn man to do hatte verstehe
stichwitz wie funktioniert es denn to do naja das ist eigentlich schon ganz nützlich doch
das ist ganz nützlich vor allem wenn das auch quer nicht nur in eigene projekt dateien
geht also zum beispiel wenn mich jetzt interessiert wo ist das hier definiert also gerade wenn man so
ein bisschen aduino zeug macht oder esp 32 zeug macht man muss doch ganz gerne mal in die source
files und reingucken und da habe ich immer so ein paar dinge die mache ich 30.000 mal am
tag auf weil ich gucken will wie sie es gemacht haben das ist doch das ist praktisch doch das
ist praktisch das gefällt mir doch das gefällt mir das hat was ja zum beispiel keine ahnung
ich ich habe letzterzeit recht oft die init funktion gesucht von von dieser von dieser
komischen display klasse doch wo ist in it genau dann sucht man immer ewig danach hier in it in
it in it sonst war es wo ist es wo ist es und jetzt finde ich übrigens nicht wo habe ich es in
it hier ist in it so und jetzt kann ich sagen bookmark und habe ich das gefällt mir doch das
hat was ich ich kenne mich wahrscheinlich werde ich nie benutzen aber ich finde die idee ist nicht
schlecht das hat was 75 zeilen na klar 75.000 zeilen nee sind nicht 75.000 aber könnten 75.000
zeilen sein weil das ist 10 plus plus da kann durchaus meine datei 75.000 zeilen lang haben
gar kein gar kein problem aber guck mal das ist das ist schon 5000 zeilen lang ne windows
und die ist ist schrecklich ich persönlich finde die beste kombination auf dem desktop
mittlerweile wirklich linux inner vm und windows unten drunter weil umgedreht funktioniert es
nicht so gut umgedreht also sprich windows inner vm unter linux geht nicht so gut wie linux inner
vm unter windows und gerade wenn man sachen noch spielen will zwischendurch oder auch mal wenn
browser mit hardware beschleunigung haben möchte was ja unter linux immer noch so ein ding der
unmöglichkeit ist und dann auch nur in ganz speziellen fällen wo es mal wenn man viel glück hat
funktioniert ist die kombination windows unten drunter linux inner vm am besten gerade mit den
mit den virtuellen desktops und windows finde ich das wirklich sehr praktisch also es ernsthaft
man merkt keinen großen unterschied zwischen dem native linux und der linux vm tap out das
was soll das sein tap out of quotes brackets was verstehe nicht was macht das
was ich verstehe es nicht
das versteht ihr das was was macht das tap out ich verstehe es nicht ich habe keine ahnung was
es macht tap out of quotes brackets
tap deaktivieren und aktivieren man sieht die nee ach keine ahnung wie ich die leiste
oben weg bekommen einfach einfach das hier weg machen jetzt wieder da jetzt wieder weg
aber mein glück hat geht irgendwann der müsste der mist da oben weg wenn du es ganz weg haben
willst musste das hier machen exclusive mode dann ist komplett vorbei aber da kommst du
dann mal richtig raus dann als spätestens wenn er raus taps schaltet sich wieder um bei dir bleibt
er trotzdem kleine stück ich glaube ja du hast recht das war glaube ich in den setting das war
glaube ich in der emulation war ich irgendwie es konnte ich dafür habe ich mit code quality
gut das ist das übliche zeug spell checker totaler müll ich habe keinen bock das geht
mir schon bei den intelli bei den jetbrain sachen so auf dem keks das standardmäßig spell checker
alles spell checker im source code braucht kein mensch ich will da komische dinger schreiben
können ohne dass ich laufend irgendwelche roten wickels darunter habe turbo console lock
das
das ist also für javascript das ist cool das ist wirklich cool
ich werde mir das ich werde mir das tatsächlich mal
also da kann man das richtig verstehe gehen wir mal in javascript rein mal gucken ob das
kommen wir gleich mal ob es richtig funktioniert auch script im html also
led blub gleich eins und jetzt muss ich was drücken turbo turbo ja das ist cool das ist
nice das gefällt mir moment ich habe ich glaube moment ich glaube ich muss nur das da das hat
was so und wenn das in einer wenn das in irgendeiner funktion drin ist haben wir keine ahnung function
mein was auch immer led eins so und jetzt das ist äußerst praktisch ihr wisst ja ich bin ein print
f debugger ein lock debugger scheiß auf breakpoints und irgendwelche anderen dinger print f beste das
ist cool das gefällt mir das das ist wirklich praktisch was für eine software nutzt max für
sie vor allem vor allem bei workstation das mag ich das gefällt mir das das ist wirklich
eine sache da haben jetzt echt mal was cooles neues gefunden was control option
kontrol option was zum deutsch option wahrscheinlich windows taste control option l und troll option
l ok es ist kontrol alt l ach das geht nicht da teppich raus kontrol alt l aber funktionieren
tut es auch nicht also funktionieren tut es nicht aber das das hat was und was option schifte und
dann kommet auch ach so das meint er mit kommet out hier macht er die debug messages alle wieder
weg das ist eine wirklich big brain erweiterung von irgendjemandem javascript sehr auf den kicks
gehen muss dass er sich sowas ausdenkt das das hat was kurz gucken ob ich was im chat übersehen
habe findest du 75k im jahr als der fox in ffm gut ja das ok ich bin fünf jahre als wie sie
ausgeliehen und im bus ja das ist gut kann man machen brauche alles nicht emoji sense das war es
für mich ne das brauche ich nicht das brauche ich nicht das brauche ich nicht in visual studio
code emojis einführen kann ich anderweitig was microsoft ai-assisted intellisens für python
typescript moment les ich das richtig ai-assisted code completion was zum teufel warum ist das warum
muss das ai-assisted sein ach so die ist schon dabei die schon standardmäßig dabei ne oder
big brain
ok was was ach das ist das gedönst das haben sie in visual studio auch schon das einzige was
die ai macht ist die meist benutzten methoden zu loggen und die die oben anzuzeigen das ist
komplett useless da haben sie auf der letzten bild oder so haben sie eine riesenwelle gemacht
und haben sie noch aus das geil und aus dem voll big brain und ai unterstützt das einzige was das
macht ist wenn du zum beispiel hier keine luft ruft console auf so und console lock ist mit
abstand die meist aufgerufene funktion in console so und das würde dir dann wenn du
console lock machst wenn du console punkt machst würde dir das ai-assist hier oben lock mit
einem sternchen anzeigen weil das die meist benutzte method komplett useless blödsinn braucht
kein mensch intellisens für css classnames hat man jetzt schon hat man doch jetzt auch schon
zwar nicht was es versteht aber die normale text completion macht das gut genug npm intelli
geben auf pass intellisens for filenames das klingt in der tarte sehr sinnvoll
das klingt tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll und ich muss gleich auf probieren wir aber noch
mal aus da wir machen morgen noch mal eine runde visual studio plugins es gibt ja so viel zeug
und heute war auch kaum zeit also sprich ich kann jetzt hier was sagen pass
ah das ist cool
ja das ist praktisch nur mal für den fall der fälle nicht dass es visual studio auch so schon kann
das kann visual studio so schon wozu sollte ich die extension jetzt installieren
und reload required
ah ok wäre ja auch wäre auch was gewesen ich glaube aber in script text und so kann
es das kann es da schon ja in script text kann es da schon aber das andere sorgt dafür dass
es überall geht weiß nicht ob man das unbedingt braucht was tepp tepp tepp nein findest du
nice ok zeig mal was ist das ok ob man ob man das jetzt mit dem auto completes unbedingt
brav all die nicht system ich weiß nicht ne erst mal nicht all language autocompletor machine
learning to help you samar mittlerweile wird echt in jedem bereich mit machine lernt way
too smart ja excellent smart und was genau macht das jetzt ach so das das gibt das macht
auch code snippets oder sowas in der richtung du schreibst dann on port und wenn du on port
ins comment schreibst weiß der schon du willst quasi den port hintendran anfügen das neo
wim plugin habe ich mal anguckt hat mir nicht gefallen hat auch rumgebackt und außerdem
ich finde es ganz gut ich werde in visual studio code werde ich übelst zum ausklicker für alles
andere habe ich ja eh mein wimm am start und wenn ich wimm will mache ich mit get craft brauche
ich net weil get wird bei mir nicht in visual studio gemacht visual studio code gemacht get
wird bei mir hardcore terminal gemacht ok das das ist mir glaube ich way too smart die extension
das könnte was cooles sein ach guck mal ok der der hat der machine lernt quasi wenn die
leute let hello schreiben dass die meistens schreiben wollen let hello gleich eigentlich
eine richtig coole idee aber ich glaube dass das eher nervig ist wenn laufend irgendwelche
vorschläge auf poppen was hältst du von kind kranken ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob das
das ist was ich gerade denke ach die geschichte das habe ich dachte ich dachte gerade an was
anderes das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert war das boards das ist einfach gut geht guise
ist ist ist überflüssig braucht keiner kommando zeile beste ist kein witz ich meine das ernst
ich mache das jeden tag und es geht nix über geht kommando zeile einzige sache wo ich es
mir gefallen lasse wenn jemand sagt er möchte möchte keine mörsch konflikte von hand lesen
lösen mit geht kommando zeile und im wimm das kann ich verstehen dann in dem mörsch
tool ok aber für alles andere kommando zeile geht kommandos es gibt nichts besseres die
ganzen addons in idees und und und sonst was was es gibt sorgt nur dafür dass man es nicht
richtig lernt was eigentlich passiert geht kommando zeile ist das einzig wahre und ich
mein wirklich ernst also es ist kein gag ich war jetzt hier manchmal absichtlich sachen
die nicht stimmen und warte dann wieder chat drauf reagiert aber das meine ich wirklich
ernst geht kommando zeile und ganz ehrlich geht kommando zeile ist auch nicht schwer
wenn man einfach nur benutzen will ja man macht einen log man macht einen checker man
guckt den pratsch an mal in tag in den kommet einen diff das sind keine 6 7 kommandos die
man braucht dann ist man fertig damit wir brauchen mal ein get crash kurz stream wir
hatten so was in der richtung schon aber der war ziemlich unvorbereitet das können wir
wirklich mal machen video stream stream ideen video stream get ok excellent leute wir gucken
an der stelle einfach morgen weiter ich gehe jetzt ins bett ich muss morgen verarbeiten
wir sehen uns morgen es gibt noch jede menge nicer plugins ich war echt überrascht wirklich
ein paar sinnvolle sachen dabei normalerweise denke ich mir immer so brauchst du brauchst
du alles nicht aber das gibt es echt ein paar sachen die machen guten eindruck
get bash naja get bash ist die windows geschichte und darin machst du get kommando zeile also
quasi das gleiche wie in was du in den inox machst also ja also gebe ich dir recht ist
wichtig ich meine halt die ganze get get kommando zeile verwenden können ist das wichtigste
was es gibt wenn man get lernen will also wir sehen uns morgen machts gut bis denn wir
sehen uns zu